[Music]
amber's in minneapolis hey amber what's
up
hi dave hi christy hope your day is
going well sure what's going on can we
help
i am currently on baby step number two
and at the beginning of the year i
started a youtube channel which has now
opened an opportunity to make some
additional income to go towards my baby
steps
my question is on my youtube channel i
try on and review clothing which
requires me to purchase quite a few
pieces from each brand
i generally return most of the samples
like once i'm done filming
but i'm currently funding this on a
credit card that i only used for that
and i only pay the minimum balance like
the minimum due each month until i get
the refund
at any given time there could be up to 4
000 on this card in rotation
is this an okay way to fund this and
like chalk it up as a business expense
or should i be approaching it in a
different way
um
yes
yes you should be approaching in a
different way having a credit card for
business or personal is a bad plan
because of the risk involved because
it's a bad plan to cash flow your
business but
credit card aside for a second and i'll
let dave explain that even more but you
should not be paying for these clothes
these ideally these brands
should be giving you free clothes to
review
for the exposure that you keep for the
exposure you should not be paying to
give them business this doesn't make
sense so your whole business model needs
to be fixed from the inside out aside
from how you're you're funding any
expenses that you have which should not
be on a credit card but i want you to go
to these brands and get them to give you
free clothes you're giving them exposure
how much are you making on youtube
so the actual youtube portion of it like
i just hit the monetization and it's
like very small eighteen dollars
yeah like after a month of doing videos
this other platform reached out to me
and they pay me thirty dollars for each
30 second to two minute clip that talks
about each project what's your
viewership
my viewership i'm just over a thousand
so it's still pretty new but i've made
in like the past
six or seven months with this other
platform i've made over twelve thousand
dollars
[Music]
okay
so the risk that you're taking from a
business perspective screwing around
with four thousand dollars
in order to make eighteen dollars or
thirty dollars or up to twelve thousand
over many many months
uh is inordinate
uh i'm not sure you got enough eyeballs
yet on the thing to get them to give you
the free clothes the way christie's
trying to talk about but basically what
you're doing is you're putting yourself
in a position of being an influencer
and uh the way influencers get paid is
they monetize
the eyeballs
they come to watch them do whatever it
is they do
and so um
that's what you know and obviously
youtube will pay you and other platforms
will pay you as well
if you can get the eyeballs but a
thousand is not not a bunch you're
getting there though that's i'm glad
you're working this
uh so uh what's your household income
overall
so my normal nine to five i make about
eighty six thousand okay
i i want you to set aside two grand
for this business maybe even out of the
business income or three grand
and just prime the pump one time by that
i mean open a separate checking account
that is just for this clothing exchange
process
because if you get stuck if one of these
companies let's say you bought a
thousand bucks from somebody and they
just said oh we're not taking that back
you wore it
um
and so your little return refund program
doesn't work anymore you now ate that
and guess what if it's on your credit
card you now have credit card debt
and so this is the risk that happens
because there's one thing we're sure of
in business
there's three things we're sure of in
business
um
it's going to cost twice as much as you
think it's going to it's going to take
twice as long as you think it's going to
and you're not the exception those are
the three rules of business
and it happens to me around here all the
time i have some great idea i think this
is going to work and we put it out there
and
six years later into the gold planner
christy's goal planner which we launched
today is a mega successful product the
first year yeah
i wasn't sure is that great idea you
know
well a lot of dadgum work for not much
money you know and so now it has turned
out to be a thing but it took twice as
long it doesn't as we thought and we're
not the exception especially and uh no
matter how enthused or enthusiastic or
um
angry i am or christy is it doesn't
matter you know we still got to she's
still got some things have to cook up
they're like good gumbo yeah you know
and so
you and in the meantime you're carrying
credit card debt
and i'm not gonna ever advise that you
called the they mean you called the
ramsey show you called dave ramsey
christy ryan asked about credit card you
knew you you knew that wasn't gonna work
i mean that was that that is predictable
we're consistent